Transcriber:
Hello, I am Makhtoum Abdalla from Sudan,
born in 2004, in Nyala, South Darfur.
And on the map, the western part of Sudan
is where you find Darfur.
For over a decade,
the state was affected [by] conflict,
which we were still reeling from.
And as a result,
since I was four years old,
my family have lived in a camp
for internally displaced people:
an IDP camp for families
that have been driven from their homes
for one reason or another,
to another part of the country.
My family was displaced
because of conflict,
and I was born in a world
full of complexity,
loss and deprivation.
But despite that,
my family and I are still here
full of hopes and dreams
for a better tomorrow.
Before the camp,
we used to live in a place
called Otash village in South Darfur.
And as the word “otash” comes from
the Arabic word “A’atshan”,
which means thirsty.
And it has been called so
for the lack of water resources
in that area.
And so the name
of our IDP camp is Otash camp.
Same name, same issue.
It's home to almost 100,000 people
from different villages.
I was very young when we left our home,
but I can remember the fear
on my family's face
as they're getting ready,
leaving everything behind.
I could see their pain,
especially on my mother's face.
I still remember.
My family were one
of the thousands of families that fled.
Not everyone was lucky,
some lost their lives
while trying to escape.
Because the journey was so dangerous,
we had to hide frequently along the road.
Where we used to live
is only two hours away,
but the journey took two days
until we finally reached a safe place,
the place that today we call
Otash IDP camp.
During the two days
it took my family to the camp,
we had nothing to eat
and only a little water.
My baby brother died from malnutrition.
And he was not even two years old.
My brother's passing affected me a lot.
That's why I decided to go to college
to study nutrition and medicine.
Just to help others and find ways
to prevent what happened to him.
In a world with so much food
and so much prosperity,
no one should ever die of hunger.
I feel like I owe it to my baby brother
to be better and do better,
so I can help people like us,
whether from Darfur
or anywhere in the world.
I have big dreams,
and I know education
is my path to reaching them.
Education is a basic right
for every child.
And it is the way
each of us can get skills,
tools and power to make
change in our lives
and in the world.
Education is a basic right
for all children,
especially for those who have grown up
only knowing violence and conflict.
And education, also, is the way
we make our future more secure
and our present more peaceful.
A generation needs power to make change.
And the greatest power
that's ever known to all
is the power of knowledge.
When I read books,
I feel like I'm no longer
in my tiny room made of hay
without electricity in the camp.
I feel like I'm confident enough to say
that I'm the captain of my destiny.
From my room in the camp,
I've been able to travel
through books to Cairo,
London and France,
and all the way to Columbia
University in New York.
And I know what most people
may think about me,
that I'm an internally displaced person.
That may be true, but I am more than that.
I am patience, I'm hope, dreams,
and with education,
I can get where I want to be.
Education in an IDP camp is hard,
and Otash has certainly had
its ups and downs.
At the beginning,
there were no schools nearby.
Now there are schools,
but they are not always free.
And we don't always have access
to electricity or access to internet
like schools in many other countries.
But education should be free
for every child,
and access to quality education
should be a priority
and available for all children.
Meanwhile, as more people
in Darfur have been displaced,
the schools inside our camp
have become overcrowded.
But still, they have big dreams too.
And in my state primary school exams,
I came in third in the ranking
out of thousands of students,
which was a huge achievement for me.
Soon I will take another test
at the end of my secondary school,
and then I hope to progress
onward to University,
moving step by step closer
to my ultimate goal.
Along the way,
I've learned to speak three languages.
I speak fluently in Arabic,
English and Turkish.
And recently, I started to learn French.
(French) J’ai de grands rêves.
(English) Learning languages
makes me feel powerful,
as they challenge my mind.
And it also makes me feel
I can communicate with other people,
which is important to a connected
and equitable world.
And also, it's one of the many ways
that can bring us all together as humans.
Because of my academic achievement,
a few years ago, UNICEF Sudan
wrote an article about me
in which I shared my biggest dream
to one day go to Columbia University
and study medicine.
And now today I am one
of UNICEF Sudan Youth Advocates,
championing the rights of other children
to access quality education.
I told you, I have big dreams.
Since becoming a Youth Advocate
with UNICEF Sudan,
I've been emphasizing the importance
of peace and education.
And I see how youth
in the camp look up to me
and how my parents and siblings
ooze with pride
with the opportunities I have been given,
which makes me feel proud.
And I love seeing everyone in the camp
wants also to fight for education.
Recently, I had the opportunity to fly
to the capital of Sudan, Khartoum.
It was the first time for me
to be on an airplane
and first time also to leave Nyala.
I even had the opportunity to meet
the prime minister of Sudan,
along with other youth
representing every state in Sudan,
which was truly overwhelming for me.
I, Makhtoum, from Otash IDP camp,
with the Prime Minister of Sudan.
But it was also an eye-opener.
I connected with other youth
who came to the capital
with a heart full of hope
and a mind filled with determination,
wanting to share their stories
from their parts in their country.
I realized that, despite our different
cultural backgrounds, we were all one.
We have the same plight and needs.
But we all wanted one thing:
peace and fair treatment
and access to services and opportunities.
And this must be true
with every child around the globe.
The visit also reminded me
that there is so much
unfairness in this world.
As I was lying in my hotel room
with A/C on and electricity,
I thought of how I struggle in the camp
to study and to sleep
because of lack of electricity.
When I study, I rely on flashlights.
I can’t help but ask the question: Why?
I realized that I'm
in so many ways so lucky
because I have opportunities
to succeed in life,
and I have the great privilege
to continue to increase awareness
about education for all children
like me and across the world.
Imagine if they were given the skills,
power and knowledge.
Imagine the difference they would make
in their life and in our world.
They have big dreams, too.
Education, just like electricity,
shouldn't just be for some,
it's a necessity and a right.
Just like hopes, dreams and opportunity.
Shining a way forward for each of us
and, in turn, allowing us to make
the world better for others.
I am Makhtoum Abdalla from Otash IDP camp,
but I am so much more than that.
I say it proudly.
With the power of education,
I can make the world a better place.
We all can.
Thank you.